welcome back to New rockstars I'm Winnie
van laningham and there's a secret
invasion of foot which means that
everybody in the new Rockstar's office
has their own conspiracy bulletin board
with enough red stringed in its
Spider-Man suit what's on my board you
ask well it all has to do with Graphics
Rebel forces and who's funding his whole
Invasion we know graphic is radicalizing
disenfranchised skrulls but who
radicalized him I've got a feeling this
Invasion goes deeper than what we've
seen and graphic is just the tip of the
iceberg it's secret Invasion season and
the easiest way to let people know that
you're not a scroll or make them think
you're not a scroll is to pick up some
merch From Nerd Riot's new secret
Invasion collection the shapeshifter P
announces that you're totally an out of
scroll which is exactly what a scroll
shirt would sit the Friend or Foe and
the one last fight shirts highlighter
buds Roadie and Nick Fury and their
potential to really be a green spin
alien you can also shop our full line of
designs inspired by Across the
spiderverse and Guardians of the Galaxy
vol 3 and keep an eye out for a very
cool Barbie Oppenheimer combo shirt that
is officially the best thing to wear on
your torso in July dropping a nerd Riot
is one of the best ways to support our
channel so join the riot over at
nerdriot.shop let's first give graphic
his dues though this scroll clearly has
the skills and motivation to lead an
invasion as we saw in this week's
flashback graphic lost his family when
they died valiantly fighting against the
cree war heroes and the skrull's
unending conflict with their sworn
Galactic Rivals as a boy graphic put his
trust in Talos and Nick Fury's word that
if he served as a spy on Fury's behalf
Fury would find the Scrolls a new home
planet but after Decades of waiting Fury
never made good on his vow he got dusted
and like 30 seconds after he returned he
abandoned his scroll buddies once again
to oversee the building of saber space
station fed up with Siri's failure to
take care of the skrulls graphics split
off his own faction and started a
movement to take over Earth flipping
Fury's high level scroll operatives to
his cause Graphics influence and assets
Run Deep he's got himself a whole
refugee camp of skrulls and his
supporters have ridiculous levels of
global influence dude has a prime
minister and a NATO official in his back
pocket not to mention he's cruising
towards introducing super Scrolls into
the MCU and this little science project
is what got me wondering if graphic is
receiving aid from benefactor we've yet
to see a benefactor who's eager to turn
Terrace c53 AKA Earth into new skrillos
we've actually already gotten a pretty
big clue as to who this could be thanks
to Talos during a little game Mama Fury
calls tell me something I don't know
according to Talos he sent out a signal
to the million surviving Scrolls and
nearly all of the Wayward shapeshifters
made their way to Earth the Scrolls that
didn't come are members of a colony a
colony led by bad boy and bird Rogue
lose Emperor droj well judging by his
name and title he seems to be a new
character made for the MCU but he's very
likely an adaptation of two comic book
Scrolls fused into one a scroll duck and
if you will the obvious first character
that inspired this Emperor is a
character called droj fenu edu a minor
character that's had a total of two
comic book appearances what's notable
about Emperor droj's namesake is that
droj fenu edu isn't nobility or Grand
military General he's a scientist droj
finu edu appears in 2007's secret
Invasion event as the Royal priest of
Sciences aka the Scrolls head scientist
this roses Forte is creating clones but
his shining achievement is perfecting a
line of undetectable super squirrels
based on the genetic makeup of earth's
greatest heroes droj venu edu is far
from Emperor material however he's
depicted as a Chinese subservient Aid
rather than a Commanding General this
makes me think that the mcu's emperor
deroj likely also draws inspiration from
another specific scroll Emperor out of
all the scroll royalty from the comics
I'd imagine that Emperor Doric VII is
the basis for the mcu's foreshadowed
scroll emperor in the comics Doric is
responsible for ordering the squirrel's
secret Invasion although he was dead by
the time it came to fruition dork VII is
also notable for being the grandfather
of the young Avenger hulkling a core
team member of a team the MCU has been
slowly building towards so how does the
mcu's emperor garage factor into
gravic's secret Invasion well for
starters he's in Emperor and a colonizer
those are two
does that lean towards political egotism
the last thing a squirrel Emperor would
want is complete Annihilation at the
hands of the cree but the second to last
thing a squirrel Emperor would want is a
rival scroll Outpost threatening their
legitimacy as Monarch Hallows put out an
Intergalactic call for skrulls and we're
led to believe that large droves of them
ended up on Earth those are squirrels
that actively chose Talos over droj and
while we don't have the hard numbers the
implication of the latest secret
Invasion Episode suggests that majority
of the surviving Scrolls came to Earth
instead of joining droge's Colony that's
gotta Sting If You're droj but instead
of holding a slap Dash squirrel press
conference at the Four Seasons total
Landscaping to assert his legitimacy I
think droj made up a shrewd conspiracy
to undermine Talos and turn Planet c53
into another Colony under his rule like
Global superpowers in the real world all
droj would have to do is find a faction
of disaffected skrulls and help fund
their grab for power so to drows ravik
would make for the perfect General to
throw a coup graphic came from a
military upbringing and lost his family
to the scroll's greatest enemy the Creed
giving them a common cause to bond over
graphic also has inside tracks within
Fury and talos's administrations and
reason to shake things up presumably
he'd also have access to similar
communication tools as Talos and would
have access to a line of communication
with George's Colony I think it's
possible that droj reached out to gravic
and stoked his anger towards Fury and
Talos kind of like Senator Palpatine and
Anakin although hopefully this time it
won't end with Sam Jackson being thrown
out a window all droj would have to do
to destabilize Earth's political
structures and make it ripe for the
taken would be to give graphic the
resources to successfully infiltrate and
overthrow Earth's Nations this is why I
think the writers chose groshvinuinu as
Emperor groj's namesake my theory is
that Emperor Roja's regime is providing
research on Super Squirrel DNA
sequencing cabratic's Rebels it's low
cost androse doesn't need to risk
sending physical resources to gravic but
the Super Squirrel research alone is
valuable enough to win Graphics War all
graphic would have to do is acquire
Super powered DNA samples on Earth to
successfully sequence his solution for
dealing with those darn pesky Avengers
if all goes according to plan graphic
will owed Roja debt and will see the
Emperor as an ally and not as the
political rival remember gravic has
pointedly said that he isn't the cause
home is the cause meaning Graphics
political Ambitions end at uniting the
skulls and giving them a new Homeworld
droj can simply install graphic as a
governor or grand general of new
skrillos and then take Earth for himself
it should also be noted that I don't
think graphic is the only Pawn we've
seen of Emperor droj clearly the scroll
agent acting as the UK's prime minister
as a secret agenda of her own an
adventure that she's also working on
behalf of drove using her political
influence to guide Graphics coup
although part of me wonders if she'll be
revealed to be scroll princess varenke
who in the comics is a political rival
of Emperor Doric and the leader of the
secret Invasion after dork dies if this
is true she could pose as an alternative
Mastermind to droj giving us a slight
alteration on this Theory wherein
instead varenke is pulling graphic
strings and not the emperor in the
comics frankly found Doric VII to be
incompetent and he banished her for
calling him out after his death she
would meet with Josh venu edu and use
his science to replace Spider Woman and
oversee the secret Invasion this
adaptation might have varanki similarly
using graphic alongside Emperor droja's
Super Squirrel research to take over
Earth but instead of turning it over to
the emperor she'll use it to claim her
position as tap scroll both taloses tell
me something I don't know responses and
the scroll council's coo scenes in this
last episode hint that skrulls are prone
to infighting overpower that's an
extremely human trait and already seems
to be a Core theme in this show about
political tension I wouldn't be
surprised if we see more instances of
Scrolls perpetuating treason and War in
their own climb to the top follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at whitneypuppy
follow new Rockstar subscribe to me
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love and thanks for
watching bye
thank you